hello my name is hugo today is a
beautiful day and i was thinking what is
the european identity so what better
place to go than brussels and find new
perspectives about it i'm here today to
talk with two amazing and inspiring
people and try to find out more about
that what is the european identity hey
i'm geoffrey everyone calls me jay
i moved to brasil's i mean to belgium
about 10 years ago originally from ivory
coast i moved here to study um because
my mom moved to europe when she was 12
and basically she lived her whole
i would say life here she grew up here
so she knew that
me coming to europe i will have
a better opportunity has i mean to to
learn something
so that's how i get here my name is osga
and i'm from turkey my mom used to come
to brussels for work and one of her
trips she took me with her i was in high
school
and it was the first time i went to
western europe and i really liked it in
brussels and i don't know if it's luck
or coincidence but now
i came here two years ago to work and
now i'm living and working in belgium
how was it the first time you arrived
here how was the cultural shock
do you have some some funny experience
one of the first cultural shock
is that i realized for the first time
that i was black
because i lived in ivory coast of course
you know you're black but you're
surrounding with your peers so it's like
yeah okay i'm like so what then you move
to
to europe
lots of caucasian people you have
everything but then again you see that
okay
actually there are lots of people that
are different than me even though we
have quotation people in in ivory coast
but it's just that there is a far far
far less number and when i took the bus
the first time
i was with my cousin then we got in the
bus
and at the very first second i felt like
everyone was looking at me and my cousin
was also black he's looking at me and
he's like
man you're just dreaming no one is
looking at you here and now after many
years i know no one was looking at me
but it was just a feeling yeah you see i
felt like i was i was different i came
here i had to
apply to get a work permit
the paperwork is not easy every year you
have to do it right and every year
you're reminded that you are you know a
migrant in this country it gets easier
every year but still every year it's a
stress i have to say it's really
inspiring to hear to both of you and
it's things that i would never thought
about it
wow just well so
after all of that what you would say is
what is to be european
i would say that to me being european is
being part of this huge community you
can even see it with erasmus
we get to know each other with all the
students that come from come from abroad
but
it just feels like one
so i would say
to me it's
being in a community it's
live with a certain standard in a
certain structure
and it's all about being united
that's what it is to me being european
yeah i mean it's very interesting but i
was also thinking a little bit like what
is the european values
because i mean if you look at europe eu
at least there's a peace project and
like as you were saying like then we are
a big community here so there are no
borders and at least we are not fighting
against each other so that rule of law
and also equality and
democracy uh these are the things that i
think make like europe or the eu like
really strong these common values they
are the you know the cement that builds
this structure together and we have to
make sure that we have this in place so
that we as a community can continue
living together
and giving each other space to be who
you who we are basically and respecting
each other
to what extent you already feel european
i went back to ivory coast um nine years
after moving to belgium for the first
time i was not used to the way they used
to live
i was not used to my old ways i had
completely changed so i was always
commenting on stuff yes but why would
you do it like this you should do it
like that and i think it makes more
sense because in europe that's how we do
and later i i get to to become a belgian
citizen
um which then emphasized this
feeling of
um
i mean i feel included
in in in this community
and
this is how
i i feel about being european
i think the
things about european
identity if i were to say about it is
that there is none you can be
whoever you want to be you can come from
what country you want to come from even
i come from ivory coast originally then
i got to become european because i kind
of
took this lifestyle
where i feel included in this community
and to me this is what is having a
european identity about
i completely agree when i
i try to picture when you say european
identity i try to picture a person and
nothing came to my mind because i think
european identity is not to be
uh you know white or black or muslim
christian or jewish or
it's to be
it is this this community and you can uh
we are still working on it but in my
mind in the perfect european identity
you should be whoever you are and still
be accepted in europe if you choose to
be european then you are european